I'm statistician from UCL Department of
statistical science this is actually my
first appearance and even these are my
first minutes at pi data and let's see
whether what I have for you here is
targeted at the right audience I'm not
so sure about that but let's see the
most important thing I want to talk
about is basically how to think about
cluster analysis yeah and probably you
were attracted by the title right so
chances are I may not have to tell many
of you what cluster analysis actually is
but still because I don't know what your
background is I will give a short
introduction to cluster analysis so
generally cluster analysis is about
finding groups and data what you see
here is you see a four dimensional data
set all the objects in this data sets
are actually bees so they are Tetragon
Euler bees and these four variables that
you see here they present represent some
genetic information about the bees and
the idea is that because of this using
this genetic information one could find
species of these bees and that would
basically mean we try to group these
bees into some groups you see some
groups already here on the screen yeah
and there are actually lots of different
methods to do this and I will quickly
run through some of them so the probably
most well known method for cluster
analysis is k-means so the idea is we
basically tried to group the objects in
the data set that are represented by
some P dimensional so here for
dimensional Euclidean points in such a
way that this sum is minimum which
basically means we assign every point to
the mean of the cluster to which it is
assigned or I should probably use this
in order to show you this and it's also
over there and we try to assign them in
such a way that this
of squares is a minimum that means that
we represent basically all the objects
in the cluster by some kind of century
which here is the mean vector and this
will give us basically compact clusters
because the objects spread in all
directions around the mean and in all
directions the distance is computed in
the same way there are some versions of
this one version is that we don't use
squares here another version is that
instead of the mean we use some object
in the data set and then you would get a
method that is called partitioning
around mid wheats okay and this is what
it does on the beast' data when looking
at plot like this you always need to
keep in mind this these are the first
two dimensions of a data set that is
actually four-dimensional so you don't
see all the information here if
something looks a bit strange then that
could be an explanation of that one
thing you see is that to some extent at
least all the clusters they are produced
here are somewhat compact right so they
are all more or less the same size yeah
and and and they all spread in the same
way in all directions okay then a
different approach model-based approach
is we could fit a Gaussian mixture model
to the data so this actually goes back
to 1894 it said you could say it's the
oldest cluster and that is this method
there is although Pearson didn't use it
for cluster analysis and the idea is we
fit a model like this where we have
proportions for every cluster that's the
parameters PI J here and we model every
single cluster by a Gaussian or normal
distribution with a mean vector a J
covariance matrix Sigma J and then we
can assign the points after we estimated
for example by maximum likelihood all
these parameters in this method the
clusters are described by a Gaussian
distribution so we get roughly
elliptical clusters and they have
flexible size and shape and how this
looks like is this and one thing that
you particularly see
remind you again write some some of this
looks somewhat weird but we only see two
dimensions out of four so there may be
something going on in the other
dimensions that explains this one thing
is you see this cluster number five here
that has a much larger spread and
spreads around number eight which has a
much smaller spread this kind of stuff
you can do with gosh mixtures with
flexible covariance matrices you cannot
have this with k-means okay and then
there are a number of completely
different approaches to cluster analysis
namely approaches that operate on this
similarity matrix so you start this
computing the dissimilarity measure for
every pair of object observations first
and this could be the standard Euclidean
distance which I've used for this data
set and but it could also be tailor-made
distances for other data formats oh I
told you something wrong actually for
this data set I use the tailor-made
distance for another data format and I
will show you how this looks like
generally what we try to find here is we
try to find a collection of similar
objects which are dissimilar to all the
objects that are not in the same cluster
now so actually what is underlying the
data is some genetic information that
looks like this so we basically have 236
tetra Gunilla beasts here and they are
characterized by 13 pairs of alleles and
these pairs of alleles are characterized
by some genotypes that have some more or
less arbitrary names so that is actually
behind the data set you saw before and
then you can define a distance between
any pair of these beasts here and that
gives you a distance matrix like this so
the information you have here is for
every pair of B so this is between B 1
and B 2 a measure how dissimilar they
are the 4 dimensional data set you saw
before is actually some kind of
Euclidean approximation of this thing
and which was generated by
multi-dimensional scaling and I will
tell you a lot of details and I
should take it in the right way right
you don't if you don't understand what
this is already you don't have to
understand afterwards I will give you an
overview what kind of stuff can be
possible and some things you are going
to understand afterwards but you you
pick the ones you want right okay so now
that we have a dissimilarity method we
can compute classical hierarchical
clustering methods and the idea here is
that you start from the lowest level at
which every single observation is a
cluster so we have 236 clusters which
are all the observations and then we
merge the two most similar observations
I think that's going on somewhere down
here and then you have through 235
clusters right and one with two
observations merged and then you go up
the hierarchy here at every stage you
join the two most similar clusters you
put them together so you have one fewer
cluster until at the end everything is
merged together in only one cluster so
you basically have a sequence of
different clusterings with all numbers
of clusters you can imagine if you want
to have a specific partitioning you have
to cut the hierarchy at a certain point
right here for example that gives you a
partition and the most frequently used
hierarchical methods are single linkage
complete linkage and average linkage and
they are defined by different ways of
defining what the difference between two
clusters is so for example single
linkage takes the minimum of all objects
and the first set and all objects in the
second set of the distances between
these objects complete linkage takes the
maximum average linkage takes the
average this goes back to 1951 SK means
well actually these are the first things
that were really intended to be cluster
analysis methods these can deliver quite
different clusterings actually complete
linkage make sure that all this molarity
is within the cluster are small where a
single linkage basically focuses of on
keeping the dissimilarities between
clusters large
so these could be very compact those
from single linkage will be well
separated but maybe spread very widely
okay few more recent methods spectral
clustering basically you do k-means but
after you have projected the data and
based on the similarities with some kind
of fancy nonlinear dimension reduction
methods right you can make out that you
are not meant to understand this if you
don't understand already but this is
what you get from it it's also different
from k-means has actually the
possibility to put together a string of
observations that may be widespread but
may belong together in a certain way and
then they are also density based methods
so the idea here is that you want to
identify clusters with modes in the
density with areas where the density is
high one of these methods is DB scan and
from 1996 and the idea is you join all
observations with neighboring points if
they are close enough and then you join
neighborhoods if they share enough
points and that gives you again
something special namely the points that
are denoted n here it will only merge
things where the density is high enough
where the density is low it will not put
objects into any cluster and these are
denoted by n here and again you see some
in the middle of this but they are very
different than the other two dimensions
okay there are lots of other issues in
cluster analysis we may be interested in
estimating the number of clusters what
does it say okay good
ah okay in principle none of these
methods requires the triangle inequality
to be fulfilled however and some
basically in implicitly act as if so in
some the implicit logic would actually
apply this so you can in principle feed
a non-euclidean and non-metric the
similarity measure in all of these
however you may not particularly when
talking about density based methods you
may not get a result that is very
sensible yeah okay so this actually one
issue I wanted to measure the similarity
definition oh actually actually I didn't
know about the normal stuff in this
conference asked questions if you want
of course then I will overrun the half
hour but whether we have them whether we
have them in the middle or whether we
have them in the end I personally don't
mind much so perhaps it's better to ask
questions on the fly and good so we
could be interested in estimating the
number of clusters certainly all of
these methods give clusters but it's not
really clear in many situations whether
there are actually clusters so we are
interested in validating them and of
course we're interested in what kind of
dissimilarity should we take and what
kind of method should we take in the
specific application and that's what the
talk mainly is about so I'm now talking
and basically for the rest of the
presentation about benchmarking and
measurement of quality and cluster
analysis and this all boils down to the
question you have a data set you have
different methods giving you different
results and the question is which
clustering is better so this is a
clustering that is produced by Gaussian
mixture model on a data set all of these
points here are eruptions of the Old
Faithful geyser they geyser in the
Yellowstone National Park and the two
dimensions here are standardized waiting
time before this eruption
then the duration of the eruption and
this is by partitioning around me to eat
so if you just look at this let call
let's call this number one let's call
this number two let's let's have a bit
of a vote what what do you think is
actually better who likes the clustering
number one which is this year more okay
that's about no but you can see it right
you you can see that some points here
are red and so the difference is some
points here are red right and and these
are black here so that that's basically
the colors are the clusters okay we have
something like 18 votes for number one
who thinks number two is better now a
few okay four or five good we will see
later in the presentation whether the
measurements that I show you will
reproduce this second thing and this is
actually an artificial data set that I
generated to highlight a certain issue
so this is number one this is number two
this was generated by having a uniform
distribution here and two gaussians here
so number one number two who likes
number one more okay at seven
who likes number two more okay that is
about twenty one good so um I wanted to
highlight one thing with this example
which is that when you do clustering you
may actually be interested in different
things so you may be interested for
example in capturing some kind of
intuitive shapes that you see here in
which case the second clustering would
be preferable or you would be interested
in having all small distances within
clusters so they're all the objects
within a cluster are similar to each
other in which case this year would be
quite problematic right because they are
very huge distances within this
clustering okay now what do we do in
order to compare different cluster
analysis methods I will come back to
both of these
data sets later and we could use real
data sets with known classes so
basically supervised classification data
sets we could use simulated data sets
from mixture distributions where we know
the truth work because we basically put
it in or we could use real data sets
without non classes now you will think
about why would one think about the last
because we want to if we know the truth
we actually can compute Mis
classification rates so that would be
easy then to compare clusterings however
and there are some disadvantages of
benchmarking with known truth namely in
data sets with non classes clustering is
actually not of real scientific interest
right why would we want to find the
classes that we already know and because
of this they actually deviate
systematically from real clustering
problems unless you find some somewhere
in the beginning at some point in time
and these classes were indeed not known
but that's not the typical situation for
these data sets well yeah so you may be
in a situation where you actually do not
know the true classes of most of the
points and you can find out the true
classes of some if you put great effort
in and yeah okay that's good I mean I
should say this appears on a later slide
I'm not going to tell you that I'm
against doing this right there are a
number of situations in which this
actually makes sense but I'm basically
going to advertise that we should also
use data sets without known classes so
indeed there are situations where this
makes sense so however M the fact that
we know certain true classes doesn't
preclude other legitimate or true
clusterings right so if you know a
certain clustering on the data set and a
method finds you another one it may be
that this other one makes sense right
and would then not be a fair thing to
discard the other method because you
learn some
thing interesting about the data set
from the other method that you didn't
know before and also classes in
supervised classification problems may
not qualify as data analytic cluster so
you may not expect a clustering method
to find them
so in summary there could be better
truth than the truth we actually know
and I give you an example for this this
is a data set from social stratification
and that we analyzed in 2013 and this is
principal components of a data set that
originally I think was 13 dimensional
every object here is a person in the
United States characterized by variables
such as income number of savings account
a house ownership and things like this
now for this data set we had some true
classes and these were standard
occupation classes and such as manual
workers managed Aryans and professionals
not working seven of them here are the
colors this is how this looks like in
the principal component plot and you
even can try to find some kind of plot
that optimally separates these known
classes from each other which way ever
you look through the data set you get to
the conclusion that these classes are
actually not data and elet analytic
clusters they they don't look anywhere
near what you think what a cluster is
they are not well separated so you
cannot expect any clustering method to
find it similar problem is if you
generate data from mixture distribution
so if I wouldn't give you the numbers of
class this year in this dataset and you
would look at it probably hardly anyone
would guess that the number of clusters
in this dataset is 5 right because this
is from a mixture of 5 Gaussian
distributions but these are arranged in
such a way that they are not really
separated from each other ok so I mean
using a non truth it's useful and fair
enough so I agree with the guy up front
here and but also we want to evaluate
clustering on data for which the truth
is not known and this is what I'm
talking about now
actually there is some of some stuff
about this already in the literature
there's a range of cluster validation
indexes measuring clustering quality and
one of the most prominent ones is the
average silhouette with introduced in
1990 by Kaufman a true CEO the idea of
this is as follows so you compute this
thing which is called the silhouette
width for every observation and the a
for every observation is the average
distance to points in its own cluster so
you have a clustering right you want to
evaluate its quality and the B here you
compute the average distance of the
object xi2 all the objects in it another
cluster to which it's not assigned and
the minimum here makes sure it's the
closest one so the one that is the best
other candidate to assign this point to
now if this object sits very comfortably
in its own cluster the BISE should be
much larger than the AIC right one
should be very close to the observations
in its own cluster and then this was we
would be positive and this intuition is
used for saying a good clustering is a
clustering where the average of the
silhouette with values is large now
generally not only this index but all
the other cluster validity indexes have
some kind of one size fit at all
approach right you have one number that
gives you the quality for a clustering
and in a situation like this where you
have very large distances within a
cluster here usually these indexes
including the ASW will be dominated by
trying to get homogeneous clusters so
pretty much all of these will pick this
before this which of course does not
agree with the majority of the people in
the room here and so actually I think
there is some kind of wrong philosophy
behind this because so my general
philosophy is there are various
different aims of clustering and in
different applications
you may be interested in different
things and I would want to measure them
separately to characterize what a method
does best instead of producing
summarizing everything in a single
number and here is a list of typical
clustering games so you could be
interested in clusters that are well
separated from each other in clusters
that are very homogeneous in the sense
of having low within cluster distances
you could be interested in clusters that
can be modeled by homogeneous
distribution of shapes like the Gaussian
or the uniform distribution you could be
interested in having a good
representation of your data by centroids
and you could be interested in having
little loss of information of the
original distance by putting them in
clusters you can actually measure this
by defining a cluster based distance
that assigns the distance of one between
any two points that are in different
clusters and zero for two points in the
same cluster you could be interested in
clusters there are regions of high
density without within cluster gaps you
could be interested in uniform cluster
sizes and some applications having
extremely small and extremely large ones
just doesn't make much sense and you
could be interested in stability so if
you basically shift the people the the
observations around a bit you want to
have something very similar and now
actually one thing to realize is that
these aims may be in conflict with each
other for which reason I created this
data set right so if you want to have
small within cluster distances this
gives you something different from
having kind of homogeneous distribution
of shapes within clusters in which sense
you don't in which case you don't want
to have the first one but the second so
in a given application you got to decide
what you want and for example if you
want to do pattern recognition in images
separation of the clusters is very
important if you want to do clustering
for information reduction and you want
to represent all your objects in one
cluster by a century
this is the most important thing that
you could be interested in and if you
want to find groups and social network
analysis you don't want to have large
within cluster gaps because then that's
not a group anymore and in some
applications you actually want to find
some underlying true classes for which
there is a scientific model that
describes how these classes came about
like for example in biological species
okay so I'm now talking about several
statistics that measure different
aspects of quality in clustering and the
first one I'm going to talk about is
measuring between cluster separation and
there are several ways of doing this
unfortunately not only are there several
possible clustering aims there are also
several ways of approaching each single
one and there are some straightforward
ideas one idea is let's see let's say we
want to look at the black and the red
cluster here to take basically the
minimum distance between any two objects
of different clusters that would give
you this or you could say we are
interested in how far the means of the
clusters are away from each other now
actually these two give you quite
different concepts of separation so the
minimum distance relies only on two
points and the century' distance ignores
what goes on at the border between the
clusters so in here so basically both of
these are kind of extreme and I wanted
to come up with a compromise between
them so this I call P separation index
here
I look at the 10% points and any cluster
that are closest to the other cluster by
which I mean and have the minimum
distance to their closest point in the
other cluster and then I compute the
average distance of these and that gives
me a separation index so here that would
be the points that are marked by cross
okay something else measuring density
mountains versus Valley so whether a
clustering captures the idea that in a
cluster the density is high between the
cluster the density is low there are two
aspects of this the first one is we want
the density to go down from the mode not
up and we want no gaps or valleys so
where the density goes down and then up
again within the same cluster and the
other one is we want that the cluster
borders are basically valleys so they
the cluster borders don't run through
density mountains I base this on some
kind of kernel density which can be
computed from the similarities and the
principle is the following so if you
compute this here the thicker points are
those that have a higher density it's
the same data set as before now I'm
going to show this as an example with
acquired we add clustering this is the
single linkage clustering with two
clusters one cluster is this point alone
and the other cluster is all these you
may not find this particularly
convincing but I use this because I want
to show you how this density index for
the bigger cluster is actually computed
so what I do is I start from the point
which with the biggest density which is
somewhere in here and magnify this bit
now and then I go to its nearest point
and I add a penalty if the density then
goes up which in the first step it comes
right because I start from the mode I go
further always I go for the closest
point to what is already connected and I
add a penalty if the density is up but
none and we collect these penalty non if
the density goes down so at some point
the density will go down so this is ret
um whenever there's red there's a
penalty so now we go through here right
this is the process and at some point we
will be in a situation where we have
very low
density and we will go somewhere where
the density is high again and that's a
huge penalty so this is what I basically
do in order to measure that this is not
a good cluster we have gone very far
down and some suddenly we go up again
right and then the whole thing goes on
and we have another fairly big penalty
here and we have a little bit of a
penalty here and then there are some
other further penalties there are added
for high-density points for which a
large amount of the density comes from
another cluster what you see here is you
see a different clustering right these
this is a three cluster solution from a
density based method and there these two
are separated clusterings and we have
some penalty here because there's high
density and in their neighborhoods there
are points with from another cluster
okay there are lots of other statistics
we could be interested in we could be
interested in the within cluster average
distance we could be interested in
within cluster similarity measure that
specifies the distance from the shape to
for example a Gaussian or uniform
distribution whatever we are interested
in and we could be interested in the
within cluster square distance to
centroid if you only are interested in
this you should do k-means because this
is what k-means does best we could be
interested in a correlation coefficient
that compares the distance that we
originally had with the distance that is
defined by the clusterings to see how
much information loss we have we could
look at the entropy of cluster sizes we
could look at the average largest within
cluster gap and we could for assessing
stability look at the variation of
clustering Zhan bootstrapped datasets
and that gives us a multi-dimensional
characterization of cluster qualities
and then we standardized all indexes to
the range 0 1 in such a way that large
is good so the numbers I will show you
from now on are always to be interpreted
in this manner their large is good so
here are some examples
the data said the artificial data set
from before so here you see actually
that this data set is better in one
respect namely the average within
cluster dissimilarity if you want to
keep that low you better better go for
this one and where us in the other
respects particularly separation because
there's a huge separation here and these
two are okay relative to their sizes and
not having and within cluster gap this
one is actually better so you basically
see in which sense one is better in
which sense the other one is better
these are six clusterings on the Old
Faithful geyser data this is from a
Gaussian mixture model with two clusters
this is partitioning around mid wheats
this is spectral clustering this is
average linkage cut so that we get two
clusters this is the weird one you saw
before sing a linkage with two clusters
and this is a density based clustering
with three and then of course again you
can compute lots of things I will only
very quickly comment on some so the pom
clustering is is this one which looks a
bit weird right from from the points
here and you see that this is actually
fairly good when it comes to average
within cluster distances but regarding
most other criteria this is worse than
the one you get from M crusts and many
others here then the strange single
linkage clustering is pretty good in
some respects so for example the
separation right has a very good
separation because this cluster here is
as well separated as possible in the
data set from the rest where us it's
pretty bad regarding some other criteria
like average within cluster distance
it's not particularly good as I showed
you before when it comes to the density
index the representation of the
information of the dissimilarities and
the clustering is also quite bad and
here what you should expect the one from
the Gaussian mixture is best when it
comes
to normality normal normal
distributional shapes of the clusters
all the others don't do such a good job
on this and you can also plot this right
for example if you want to look at the
density index and you now may be
interested in all these methods over
several different numbers of clusters
you realize okay M quest was the best
for two clusters but you have some other
methods that give very good results for
higher numbers of clusters yeah and then
I'm very close to the end so the main
message here is that the clustering
quality is multi-dimensional and what I
want to have is I want to have a
multi-dimensional evaluation clustering
methods behavior if you still want to
have a single value if you apply
clustering to a specific data set you
can compute a weighted mean what you'd
need to think about is how important
which aspect of clustering is to you and
because that comes from the application
right the statistics cannot decide that
this can be used for benchmarking
comparing different clustering methods
without known truth but of course and
which is something you may be more
interested in this can also be used if
you just have your own data set to
cluster and you want to know in what way
different methods compute a cluster
these data and what is required and I
didn't really talk about that as you
need some kind of standardization that
makes different indexes and number of
clusters comparable much of this is
implemented in the our package fvc PC
but not all I made I'm not sure whether
that's a wise decision right I'm talking
about current research that is going on
so I'm not talking about a fancy package
that already can do all these things in
a particularly user-friendly way that's
what you get when you invite the
scientists from university sorry and
it's not important but nobody told me I
should do something in cut I actually
never used pipe okay
III didn't when they asked me to present
here I think they didn't want me to say
this but nobody to want me again so I
just didn't what what we also do a group
of people where my name is in it but not
in the first place this is the interfere
international well these are some people
from the International Federation of
classification society and we want to
set up a cluster benchmarking repository
with some datasets that can be used for
benchmarking and the different thing
between this and things that you already
know like machine learning repository
UCI and stuff is that we want to have
them documented in such a way that you
can actually from the information get
what kind of clustering you may want
there the work is supported by EPSRC and
i also want to do a little bit of
marketing so this came out in December
2015 it's a wonderful book you should
give it to all your friends and family
because they will all love it
and yeah so that's it thank you very
much
okay lots of questions I think the first
one is always here is actually something
that Shasha do should I do that okay
good so well what is this yeah okay so I
was asked what to do in case of missing
data now actually I personally so so I
haven't involved missing data in the
research that I'm doing right now but
the thing is that missing data from my
point of view would be handled first by
the clustering method so the question
there is for example how to design a
dissimilarity measure in case of missing
values and there are several approaches
like for example if you have categorical
variables you can make it another
category or you can tweak the formula in
such a way that missing data are
weighted out and things like this but it
doesn't directly feature in my research
right now okay
and I'm working on that the thing is
that like the question which the best
clustering is also well the number of
clusters is he asked for how can this be
used to find the right number of
clusters so also in this respect and it
is very important what is required in an
application so the rough answer I can
give to that is basically if you know
the weights that the different criteria
should have in your application of
course you can piece together a single
index and then you can of course use it
to compare different numbers of clusters
there are some details about how exactly
to make them comparable on which I'm
working but I mean if you if you can
come up with one weighting right away
that's what you have yes please
so the key thing about this is mixed
types of variables right so you have
categorical variables you have
continuous variables actually M in this
paper let let me bring this up again
where we analyzed the social
stratification data this one we this
this is a reference that I can give part
of this paper is a discussion how to do
this and there there is a certain scheme
so it requires you to think about how
different comparing with a continuous
data to categories in your categorical
data should be and one possibility that
we explored there is to think about the
variance the contribution to the
variance of the overall distance and
that you get from your categorical data
if you coded s dummies and then you can
put a weight in there that makes sure
that this has the same contribution to
the variation then a continuous variable
but there there are a number of detailed
discussions on this in this paper I
think if you Google Chanukah at Leo 2013
you may find that further questions I'm
not responsible for timekeeping here
right that's that's up to the chair okay
good yes please
and we're really the first thing is I
think about what specific application
this is so what the requirements are I
think there's a basic distinction that I
would want to make first which I call
the distinction between constructive and
realist clustering so a typical problem
is where you would usually something use
something like k-means is that you are
not really interested in finding density
values and making the statement okay
there are some two different groups you
just want to reduce information so that
you can handle the data in a better way
and in such applications you usually
want to have things like small within
cluster dissimilarities and you want
often also a good representation by
centuries and that would lead you to
methods like k-means commonly linkage
and so on or on the other hand if you
want to have something that feels like
belonging together where you could kind
of postulate there's some underlying
thing going on that produces particular
shapes you would rather go either in the
direction of having a mixture model if
you have some idea how you would want to
model this statistically or in the
direction of methods that focus much
more on separation such as spectral
clustering for example so so that would
be the rough thing and but of course if
I think like this I can also use the
criteria run lots of different ones and
see what the criteria give okay
more please yeah yes please
No well I actually I took this out of
this presentation but I've actually
worked on this I'm currently thinking
about how to involve a lesson oiz in
these criteria however also there are
clustering methods that are designed in
such a way that they are more robust to
outliers than others I mean particularly
off the methods I showed you there is
this density based approach where low
density points are actually discarded
right so they are not integrated in
cluster if you fit something like gosh a
mixture one approach is you could add a
mixture component there is a very very
very large uniform and that should catch
all the outliers so and I've done some
work on this so there is that this there
are certain methods that that are
designed for dealing with this last one
indeed
okay so the question is there are
actually several cluster analysis
methods that require some specification
of some kind of hyper parameters one of
these is number of clusters another one
is for example the DB scan method has a
size of a neighborhood for which the
method is looking in order to make of
these high-density regions and the
question is whether I would actually go
through several of these and compare
them with these methodology and my
answer is and that's a possibility
sometimes I personally I mean really to
some extent it depends on how much time
you have and how many things you want to
compare sometimes there are default
choices of these and one thing
you need to realize I have given some
other presentations elsewhere about the
number of clusters problem is although
there are methods to pretend that
pretend you to estimate the number of
clusters without requiring such
specifications themselves that that's
actually not true right if you think
about two Gaussian populations and you
put them closer and closer and closer
and closer together in most applications
there is a certain point where there
they are so close you would rather treat
them as one cluster then s2 and
generally a statistical formal method
cannot know where the border line is
every method that works without such
such a specification makes a
specification for you and you don't see
it and therefore sometimes I think
instead of fixing something that you
have to fix in order to estimate the
number of clusters you may well also fix
the number of clusters that's not the
worst thing that you can do so quite
generally I think this is a very subtle
issue and certainly you have the option
to compare lots of things according to
these statistics and but you also
restrict yourself and therefore and
sometimes you know okay I should be
going for a low number of clusters not
for high one
things like this